[موسيقى]
اول مره صار فيه شيء ثقافي في هذه المدينه
للتاريخ كان شركه سياحيه بعمله عمله مسرح
في الهواء الطلق على البحر يعني في الشاطئ
يعني مؤقت وعملت في المسرح
سهرات موسيقيه وكذا وانا اكتشفت الحكايه
لانه
وقتها كنت احب راضي شنكار
سمعت ان راح يجي في اطار مهرجان باصيله
هنا
بدايه السبعينات
راحت لاحظت على طول
هذه المدار اللي فيه الجداريات
الاشياء الفنيه
تعلمهم ان يحبوا بلدهم
كنا هنا في اصيله في ندوه عن المفكر عبد
السلام بن عبد العال قامه من قامات المغرب
الثقافيه ودائما في هذه المدينه الحميمه
المصانع بالحب اولا من عمدتها الوزير محمد
بن عيسى ومن اهلها وفنانها
نلتقي بمبدعين جاؤوا اليها للمشاركه في
موسمها السنوي بكل جهات العالم
وزير الثقافه السابق والشاعر والروائي
محمد الاشعري ليس غريبا عن هذه المدينه هو
ابن المغرب الكبير الذي لكل مدينه فيه سحر
خاص وجمال خاص ومهرجان يحتفل بكل ذلك
محمد الاشعري هو من ناحيه مولاي ادريس
الزرهون على تخوم مدينه فاس من تلك
النواحي التي كتبها وكتبته وسماها جنوب
الروح في روايته الاولى هو مثقف
كونته تجربه فكريه وثقافيه ونضاليه مؤسسه
شاعر وروائي وصحافي ومناضل دفع ثمن مواقفه
كحال والده سابقا وكحال بعض مثقفي جيلي ثم
جاء وزيرا للثقافه في زمن التحولات حيث
حول الوزاره الى ورشه ابداعيه ميدانيه في
كل نواحي المغرب
وله في كل هذه الادوار والصفات نتاجات
ميزت حضوره في المشهد الثقافي المغربي
والعربي
ولاننا في اصيله اخذنا المكان الى لغته
الى مكانه الاول الذي سماه جنوب الروح كما
سلف الذكر والى معنى الكتاب عنه وعن
قدرتها على حفظه من النسيان
هي الكتابه ايضا تسعى الى تخليد الى تخليد
نفسه وتخليد من
حيث لا ندري من يكتب فيها والله انا شخصيا
لا لا اؤمن بهذه النظريه النظريه
يعني يكفي يكفي يعني حتى نكسر غرور الشاعر
او غرور الروائي يكفي ان ادخله الى مكتبه
كبيره
[موسيقى]
ونساله كيف سيجد له مكانا بين كل هؤلاء
الكبار الذين
دعوا في الشعر وفي الروايه وفي غيرها من
من اجلس الادبيه
لا اظن ان هناك حاجات اولا ذاتيه
تدفعنا للكتابه
وهناك ايضا مشترك يجعلنا نحاول الاجابه
على بعض الاسئله بالكتابه بالادب
والادب
بهذا المعنى من الممكن ان ان يكون وسيله
لفهم العالم
ولفهم التبدلات التي تطرا عليه وفي نفس
الوقت ينتج
جمالا خاصا
ونحن لا يمكن ان نقول لا داعي لان ننتج
هذا الجمال في لغتنا العربيه وفي بلدنا
المغرب فقد فهناك جمال انتجه المانو الفرن
والصينيون كل
حضاره وكل لغه
يفترض ان تنتج جمالها الخاص
وخيالها المشترك وذاكره المشتركه وفي هذا
الاطار نحن نساهم
كلنا على قدر امكانته في تحقيق هذا
المبتغى من
وجود ادب في لغه ما
ولكن فكره الخلود اظن
الاحساس بزوال الاشياء هو الانسان لديه
قدره قدره معينه
يرسم او يعمل قطعه مسيئيه او يكتب نص ادبي
او يصور يعني اهم وسيله هي التصوير
المباشر للامكنه التي قد لا تراها مره
اخرى يعني انا هذا القصد انه هو كتابه
احيانا عم بحكي عن الكتابه عن الامكنه هي
تسعى لتخليص الامكنه من من النسيان في نفس
الوقت اظن انه
الاهم من حمايه الامكنه من النسيان هو
جعلها ماده محيه بالكتابه الكتابه
والا فان كل شيء
لابد ان ينال نصيبه من النسيان
وانا الروايه التي نشرتها في بدايه
التسعينات عن عن القريه لم تكن بهدف توثيق
لهذه القريه
وتخليدها في في صوره
معينه من خلال روايه جنوب الروح اسمها
ولكن كيف عاشت هذه القريه
كيف عاشت الشخصيات في هذه القريه كيف كانت
تعيش ماذا كانت تنتج من من خيال
ومن قيام جماليه
وكيف ان هذه القريه التي نتجت من هجره
سرعان ما تبددت في هجرات اخرى
واصبح المكان الذي كان اهلا بالسكان وهكذا
اصبحت فارغ اليوم
في هذا
المرور من الانبثاق الى الانطفاء
هناك حياه
لن استطيع
انقاذها من الفناء بالكتابه ولكن
الكتابه
تجعلني في تصالح ما عدا الفناء جميل جميل
نعم وربما نكتب او تكتب من دون ان تدري
انه انت تسعى لشيء من هذا بهذا المعنى
لانه انت عم تكتب هناك الكثير من الاشياء
التي تدفعك الى الكتابه وتنساها تماما
تماما هو الكتابه اظن يعني النص مثل
اللوحه في اللوحه كثيرا ما يلجا الرسام
الى انتاج طبقات متتاليه يمحو بعضها بعضا
وبالنهايه نحن نرى الطبقه الاخيره
الطبقه الاخيره ولكن لا نتصور ان خلفها
توجد طبقات طبقات كثيره هي التي ساهمت في
تشكيل
ما نراه وكذلك في الكتابه ايضا اظن اننا
نسعى الى او نكتب
نصوصا فوق نصوص فوق نصوص ونصل في نهايه
الامر الى النص الذي يقرا وايضا هذا النص
الذي يقراه يحمل ايضا هذه الطبقات يعني
لنقرا خلف السطور او تلك الطبقات الخفيه
في النص يعني هناك نعم في كل نص هناك
نص مضمر ونص مرجع جميل نعم لا اعتبر ان
ان النص الذي نكتبوه ونص نهائي
من الممكن ان نعود اليه ونكتبه مره اخرى
ونحن لا نفعل سوى ذلك في الواقع
عبر كل نصوصنا نعود دائما الى نص اصلي
كتبناه ونسيناه ثم نعود اليه بطريقه اخرى
نعود اليه من زمن اخر ومن حياه اخرى ومن
شخص اخر لان الشخص الذي يكتب اليوم الذي
كان يكتب قبل عشرين سنه
يعني في شيء من الحزن هذا الكلام على فكره
يعني الحزن الجميل ايضا
هي الحياه هكذا هي هذا المزيج من الممكن
والمستحيل من الفرح والامل والحزن والقسوه
اما الكتابه فهي هذا الملاذ الذي ننجو به
لنزاول الحياه او نحتفل بها وكل على
طريقته
[موسيقى]
اسمعوه قريبا ذلك السيل الذي يدنو
كانه احصنه مروعه
منذ زمن بعيد اسمعه كما لو كنت اسمع
البدايات التي انبتت الجبال والضفاف
والحجاره
كلما امتلات روحي بخواء المسافات
سمعت الهدير قادما فقلت ان الخرائط كلها
ستموت حتما بما فيها خرائط الحيره التي
اذرعها جيئه وذهابا بانتظار موت المتاهه
وستبزغ ملامح طريه من الطوفان الجديد
يقال يعني الذين كتبوا عن شغلك انه يوجد
مقدار جميل وعالي من السرد ايضا في قصيده
محمد الاشعري ربما بطريقه غير غير واعيه
وغير مفكر فيها
من بدايات الشعريه
انصرفت الى تركيب حكايات نعم الى حكايه
نعم من خلال القصيده وربما ابرز عمل كان
لي في هذا الاطار هو ديوان سيره المطر
وسيره المطار هو عنوان القصيده الاساسيه
في هذا الديوان
وهي نوع من الاستعاده البطيئه والمفصله
لصبيحه واحده في قريه في بيت قروي وهذا
الاستعاده من هي من طفولتي
وانتبهت الى ان المجال الذي وضعته اطارا
للقصيده ومجال فقير جدا فقير في الاحداث
فقير في الاشياء فقير في مكونات المكان
ولكن في هذا الفقر المدع
هناك كميه من
الجمال المتوحش
والغير المعلن عن نفسه
لا لا يصدق
وحاولت ان احكي هذه الصبيحه التي شهدت في
نفس الوقت حدثا دراميا هو موت اخي صغير في
ذلك اليوم وخروجه صبيا وهذه حقيقه يعني
وخروجه صبيا بين يدي والدي الى المقبره
ولكن في نفس الوقت هناك ام تصنع خبزها
وشخص اخر يكنس الفناء الداخلي
لي وهناك خوخه يابسه قرب البئر اشياء من
هذا النوع هي التي اسست لهذه القصيده لهذه
القصيده هي التي كتبتها يوم ماطر فقير
ليست فيه اشياء
خارقه للعاده ولكنه يوم
لكنه يوم
تجربه في في الحكي الشعري اذا صح هذا
القوصطلح
رافقتني بعد ذلك
سنوات
الحجر الاساس اللي ربما انا قلت لك لم
افكر في الامر
بهذه الطريقه لكن صاحبني الى اليوم طالما
هاي يعني هذه الحادثه القصيده يعني تتحدث
عن هذا اليوم عن هذه العائله
خلينا نتحدث شوي عن هذه العائله يعني محمد
الاشعري طبعا معروف مناضل وزير وشاعر كبير
وكاتب ومثقف وناقد وصحفي يعني
ولكنني كل اللي بيعرفوا عن عن البدايات
الاولى يعني من اين اتى يعني
ماذا عن تلك العائله عن تلك البيئه عن تلك
القريه اللي اسمها جنوب الروح سميتها
قريه صغيره طبعا نشات من هجره من الريف
الى ضواحي
وانا ولدت في في عائله فقيره جدا في لم
يكن هناك غني في القريه على فكره
كل الناس فقراء ومبسوطين من انهم على فكره
انا دائما اقول انه
لسنوات
عشت الفقر في القريه
ليس كشيء درامتك لكن كشيء عادي اذا كانت
الحياه هكذا كانت الحياه فقط يعني بدون اي
مبالغات دراميه
ومن هذه في هذه القريه
دخلت اول صف مدرسي
وبعد السنه الاولى انتهت المدرسه في
القريه لان الدوله فكرت في بناء الصف
المدرسي الاول ونسيت ان تبني الصفوف
الدوليه مش معقول
فخلاص يعني انتهت المدرسه خلص العلم خلص
العلم
فاخذني والدي الله يرحمه الى قريه اخرى
قريبه قريبه لكنها في منحدر
فيعبرها وادي
وكنا ثلاث اطفال من هذه القريه نذهب الى
المدرسه الجديده
يوم كانت هناك امطار غزيره
في الوادي امتلا يا الهي وصار هديرا جبارا
لا يمكن عبوره اطلاقا ونحن اطفال
فكان والدي من الجهه الاخرى يناديك
ويقول
لاقفوا خلاص توقفنا بعدين هو دبر امكانيه
ايواءنا في القريه هذه التي كنا فيها
وبعدها قرر ان ياخذني الى مدينه مكناس
لمتابعه دراستهم هناك
ووضعني عند عائله خاف عليك
عند عائله هناك
وفي هذه العائله تعرفت لاول مره على
مدرستي
ومدرستي كانت تحمل اسما غريبا هو مدرسه
الحبس القديم
فكانت فاء الخير في
كتبت هذه الاشياء
بعدها رجعنا من
الوالد قرر في نهايه المطاف ان ياتي الى
مدينه
واستقرينا هناك وهناك تبعت دراسه
الابتدائيه والثانويه وبعدين جئت
للثانويه في مكناس وكنت في القسم الداخلي
خلال ثلاث سنوات وبعدين جئت للرباط لكليه
الحقوق
والدك شهد بعض تجلياتك ابدا
لذلك لم يرى كتبت له قصيده اهداء لوالدك
لا كتبت اشياء يعني فيها لها علاقه بوالدي
لانه
بقي
رغم انه متى
صغيرا
وانا كنت طفل في وقت ما مات الا ان تاثير
كان قوي جدا في نفس في حياتي
لسببينو ان كان هو
مناضل في الحزب الاشتراكي الحزب الوطني
كانت وطني واعتقل عده مرات وانا عشت هذه
الاعتقالات كطفل
وعشت عودته من هذه الاعتقالات
وفي احدى عودته لم يعمر طويلا بعدها حوالي
سته اشهر وتوفي عزب يعني ولذلك لا لا اظن
تعذب نفسيا
وهو كان كان شخص
تقليدي يعني
في مدينه فاس ولكن لم يكن محافظا كانت
تقليديا ولكن لم يكن محافظا كان منفتحا
فبهذا المعنى كان كان مؤثر كتير في حياتي
في نصك اظن طبعا رغم انه لم اعيش معه
كثيرا وبظنك يعني ذهابك الى الى النضال
هيك البحث عن العداله والحريه يتضمن شيء
بين هلالين يعني كلمه السر من هذا القهر
اللي عاشوا والدك هو هو الشعور بالظلم
يبدا فرديا يبدا فرديا لان الوعي
بالاشياء العامه
لا نمتلكه من البدايات الطبيعي
فمن المؤكد انه كان عندي ميل
للتمرد
بسبب هذا الشعور بالظلم واللي هو نفسه
شعور
ملتبس يعني مش لا استطيع مثلا ان اضع
قباله هذا الشعور بالظلم المجرم الحقيقي
الذي فعل ذلك لكن تدريجيا
يعني انتقل الوعي الفردي بهذا الظلم الى
الى وعي جماعي ومسيس ومفكر فيه
يكون بريء بالاول ثم بالاخر تنظر له يعني
هذا امر طبيعي الحياه والمعرفه والقراءه
والوالده شو كان لها تاثير عليك تاثير قوي
ايضا لانه
عندما مات الوالد كانت
تزال صغيره
ولكنها نظرت نفسها
بطريقه صوفيه تماما
لتربيتنا ومتابعتنا وهي كانت اميه ولكن
كان لها ذكاء
اجتماعي وانساني خارق للعاده ولذلك انا
اتذكر دائما
انها كانت
تحاسبني على عمل المدرسي من دون ان تكون
على علم بحرف واحد ممادرسه ولكنها كانت
تحس لانني مقصر وهو
وتعرف كيف تعود به الى الطريق
ما بيتكرروا
ابناء هذه هذه العوائل المتواضعه المحبي
للحياه بيكون عندهم شيء مختلف
تعرف انا ساقول لك شيء
انما عينت في حكومه عبد الرحمن اليوسفي
وزيرا تعرف الحزب الاتحاد الاشتراكي صار
يعني يسير الحكومه والحكومه نعم وله
نسبه الاكبر في الوزراء ولكن في جيناته
انه حسب معارض
فصار يعني اقوى معارضه للحكومه هي الحزب
الحكومي
صار يعرض نفسه
في احدى اجتماعات اللجنه المركزيه بحضور
الاستاذ عبد الرحمن اليوسفي الذي كان يراس
الاجتماع يعني كان هناك صخب كبير في حول
نقد الحكومه واعضاء الحكومه وما تقوم به
وماذا تقوم به الى اخره فانا في تدخل ذكرت
شيء يعني بعد ذلك
صار يحكى في كثير من المجالس وقلت لهم
انظروا انظروا الينا
لاول مره في تاريخ المغرب جزء كبير من
وزراء هذه الحكومه ابناء ارامل وابناء قرى
مجهوله وكانوا سجناء وكانوا انظروا هذا
وحده كافي
لتدليل على ان صفحه جديده قد فتحت في
التاريخ المغرب طول الادب يمحو الضرائن
يعني يعطي السكينه او القدره على الصفح
القدره على الصفح جميل
هكذا بدات الحكايه مع محمد الاشعري من
قريه فقيره هناك كتبها وحملها مثل امانه
كصوره والده الفقيه الذي انقذه من السيل
والصمت
نتابع في جزء اخر مع الشاعر والوزير
والروائي محمد الاشعري مسارات هذه التجربه
لنلقي الضوء على نتاجه الادب والمعرفي
[موسيقى]